[Music]
what happened to god pete
i'm still into talking about no we're
not doing that what was that
did you just run a christian commercial
he's trying to shovel it under the mat
like this is my buddy he's a pastor but
i'm going to talk to him about surf
things
[Laughter]
this isn't about jesus though jesus is
good this is about water
you know what's the greatest part about
that is that in the final joke and i
thought this is very you tell me what
i'm going to say about the punchline of
that that video piece you did with the
pastor he should have carried me well
yeah you automatically put yourself in
the jesus position
[Applause]
you set up this joke this is this is
what i i like and hate about you
is that
you set up this joke can we reenact
the the popular you know thing that you
hang on your wall at the dentist at the
dentist
or i troubled people's homes yeah
it's never the happy people he's
carrying me today karen
he's carrying me today
let's reenact that
with me as jesus
i would normally relent and say that it
was my ego that said i wanted to be the
christ figure yeah in this case it's
because i'm i was beefier
now you see how far your ego has gotten
away from you
you don't even know that you're still in
the grips of your ego pete
get down and pray
this is like the baptism scene and there
will be blood
give me the blood
you don't want to do it i don't want to
do it
[Music]
you